>>> TONIGHT THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE MEETS TO HOLD MARK
MEADOWS IN CONTEMPT FOR DEFYING
A SUBPOENA FOR MORE DOCUMENTS
AND FOR A DEPOSITION.
THE COMMITTEE CALLS MEADOWS A
CENTRAL INSURRECTION WITNESS AND
IS RELEASING EVIDENCE TO BACK IT
UP INCLUDING AN EMAIL THAT
MEADOWS SENT SAYING THAT THE
NATIONAL GUARD WOULD BE READY TO
PROTECT PRO-TRUMP PEOPLE AROUND
JANUARY 6th.
PART OF A LENGTHY REPORT
DETAILING MEADOWS' INTERACTION
WITH KEY BIG LIE REPORTERS.
JOINING ME IS CNN'S DANA BASH
AND JOHN HARWOOD AND TIA
MITCHELL OF "THE ATLANTIC JUNL
CONSTITUTION."
MEADOWS WAS COOPERATING AND THEN
PULLED BACK.
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO HIS LAWYER
SENT THIS TO THE COMMITTEE
SAYING, NO, YOU SHOULDN'T DO
THAT.
WE SHOULD KEEP NEGOTIATING AND
THE COMMITTEE SAYS OKAY, FINE,
CONTEMPT.
>> YEAH, AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE IS SAYING, YOU KNOW,
YOU WERE COOPERATING.
YOU GAVE US DOCUMENTS AND NOW
YOU DON'T EVEN WANT TO TALK TO
US ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS THAT YOU
GAVE US TO HELP US UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE REDDING IN THE STORY
BEHIND THEM.
IN ADDITION, THE DOCUMENTS SHOW
THAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT
RALLY ON JANUARY 6th WITH PEOPLE
WHO WERE NOT THE PRESIDENT, WHO
WERE NOT WORKING AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, SO I THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
HE CAN TRULY CLAIM EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, AND THEY HAVE, YOU
KNOW, THE EVIDENCE TO SAY, WELL,
IS ALL OF THIS PROTECTED?
>> AND THE EVIDENCE IS
IMPORTANT.
REMEMBER, WE FOCUS TOO OFTEN ON
THAT HORRIFIC DAY.
THE COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO GO
FROM ELECTION DAY TO
INSURRECTION DAY.
WHO WAS THE COORDINATION WORKS
KNEW WHAT AND WHO WAS RAISING
MONEY?
AND MEADOWS WAS PRETTY CENTRAL
TO A LOT OF BIG QUESTIONS, JOHN
HARWOOD.
HE EXCHANGED TEXT MESSAGES WITH
AND PROVIDED GUIDANCE TO AN
ORGANIZER OF THE JANUARY 6th
RALLY ON THE ELLIPSE AFTER THE
ORGANIZER SAID THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN CRAZY AND I NEED SOME
DIRECTION.
IN ADDITION, MARK MEADOWS
PARTICIPATED IN ANOTHER CALL
WITH MR. TRUMP, MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, ATTORNEYS FOR THE
TRUMP RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN AND
300 STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
DISCUSS THE GOAL OF OVERTURNING
CERTAIN STATES' ELECTORAL
COLLEGE RESULTS.
LET ME TRANSLATE TO DISCUSS THE
GOAL OF FINDING A WAY TO CHEAT
AND REVERSE THE ELECTION.
>> HE WAS IN DEEP.
HE'S TRYING TO MICK A
DISTINCTION AND THE WHEN THE
POWERPOINT SURFACED HE SAID HE
DIDN'T RECEIVE THIS OR FACE ON,
BUT IF YOU'RE THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF AND YOU DON'T
SHUT DOWN DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS,
YOU'RE PART OF IT, AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT NOT JUST TRUMP AND
NOT JUST A FEW EXTREMISTS MIKE
FLYNN, SYDNEY POWELL AND RUDY
GIULIANI ON THE OUTSIDE WERE
INVOLVED.
PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
MOST SENIOR POSITIONS WERE
ASSISTING THIS PROCESS,
SUSTAINING THIS PROCESS
ENCOURAGING MANY JUMP TO GET
GOING.
HE'S BEEN INDICTED.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INDICTED AND
I WANT TO STAY ON THE GOOD SIDE
OF THE EXTREMIST WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THAT'S
TRUMP.
THAT'S WHY WE SAW THE FIGHTS
WITH THE STEVE BANNOS AND MARK
MEADOWS TEND TO OVERSHADOW WHAT
HE IS BUILDING.
WHEN YOU READ THROUGH WHAT HE
WAS PART OF, HE'S CENTRAL AND AT
TRUMP'S SIDE AND HE HAD
EVERYTHING THAT CAME HIS WAY AND
HE KNOWS HOW IT WAS GIVEN TO AND
REACTED TO BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP FAMOUSLY DOESN'T
TEXT.
HE DOESN'T EMAIL AND HE
COMMUNICATES WITH HIS TOP AIDE,
HIS ASSISTANT AND ALSO PEOPLE
WHO ARE NEAR HIM.
HE SORT OF BARKS OUT ORDERS,
TEXTS SOMEBODY "X" AND TEXTS
SOMEBODY ELSE "Y" AND ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IS HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
IN HERE, BUT EVEN IF IT'S NOT,
LIKE JOHN WAS SAYING, THE NOTION
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE -- YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE MOMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
STOP, TAKE A BREATH AND SAY THIS
IS NOT NORMAL.
THIS IS NOT OKAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
PARTICIPATING IN ANY OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS, NEVER MIND WHAT THE
TEXT MESSAGES BELIEVE WHICH IS
SCORES OF DISCUSSIONS IS
REMARKABLE.
OTHER THING THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT BEFORE I CAME ON IS
ANOTHER REALITY THAT'S COMING TO
LIFE IS MIKE MELD OWES G MILL
ATONIGHT.
VIST ACCOUNTS.
SIGNAL WHICH IS A MORER IS TEXT
MESSAGE APP AND CAN YOU IMAGINE
IF HILLARY CLINTON DID THAT?
>> ANOTHER ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
RAN HILLARY CLINTON UP THE FLAG
POLE FOR HAVING AN EMAIL SERVER
INSIDE THEIR HOUSE IS NOW DOING
TEN TIMES THAT WITH PRIVATE
EMAIL ACCOUNTS.
MEADOWS SAYS AS YOU MAKE THE
POINT THAT HE RECEIVED A LOT OF
THINGS FROM A LOT OF THE TRUMP,
MY WORD, CRAZIES OUT THERE
TRYING TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
INCLUDING THIS POWERPOINT
PRESENTATION AND VIRTUALLY IT'S
HOW TO STAGE A COUP.
WHAT THINGS CAN WE DO TO GUM UP
THE WORKS AND GORSUCH TO HIM BY
AN ARMY COLONEL WALDRON WHO
BELIEVES SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
>> A LOT OF MOVEMENTS OF VOTE,
DIRECT ACCESS TO PENNSYLVANIA,
VOTING PRECINCTS, COUNTY
TABULATION CENTERS, WISCONSIN,
MICHIGAN, NEVADA, ARIZONA,
GEORGIA, ALL OF THAT COMING IN
DIRECTLY FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES,
CHINA BEING THE PREDOMINANT ONE.
>> IT'S -- IT'S LUNACY.
IT'S LUNACY.
I WILL LEVITATE, YOU KNOW.
CHINA WAS NOT -- CHINA WAS NOT
RUNNING THE VOTE COUNT IN YOUR
STATE OF GEORGIA OR ANY OF THESE
OTHER STATE.
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED.
AGAIN, THE WHITE HOUSE XHOEF OF
STAFF GETS A DOCUMENT FROM
SOMETHING HIKE THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM, THIS.
WHO DO I SHARE IT WITH.
>> THAT'S THE RESPONSE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING THIS ON YOUR
SHOW A LOT.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU HAVE NOTHING TO
HIDE, THEN WHY NOT ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS, AND THAT IS WHAT HAS
FORMER MEADOWS LOOKING, YOU
KNOW, SPOT SO GREAT IN THE
LOYALTY BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT HIM
TO JUST ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THESE DOCUMENTS.
>> BACK TO THIS FOR ONE SECOND.
WHAT ARE REPUBLICAN ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THIS SAYING RIGHT
NOW, ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THAT TEL